this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream home to thousands of
nonfiction documentaries from some of
the best filmmakers in the world
follow the link below to start your free
trial today
[Music]
if you're tired of seeing feel-good
commercials about these uncertain times
and home depot
won't stop emailing you about what
they're doing to help prevent kovid
you're not alone
it gets old after a while it's
especially strange to see the world
spiral into dysfunction while every
online advertisement is peppier and more
saccharine than ever
we get it big companies need to pivot to
new business models to keep their
numbers up while people are holed up
inside
but besides trying to ignore sickly
sweet hulu ads what most of us are doing
is wondering
when will the world be safe again in
this episode we're going to look at
historical precedence for pandemic
recovery and try to come up with a rough
estimate of when the outside world will
feel more normal
as a disclaimer we won't be talking
about any of the debate over reopening
various countries for the sake of the
economy or the various astroturf
protests happening in america
those are important topics but this
video will strictly be about historical
precedence
before we begin the terms covid19 and
coronavirus refer to the disease itself
while sara's cove ii refers to the virus
that causes the disease
to avoid unnecessary confusion regarding
sars and kovid the world health
organization has taken to referring to
the virus as covid19
or the virus responsible for covet 19.
in this episode the terms coronavirus
and kovid19 will be used interchangeably
for both the virus and the disease
now we'll start by looking at the
current numbers for covid19
as another disclaimer we're still very
much in the throes of this pandemic
these numbers will change quickly and by
the time this video is uploaded they'll
already be out of date
this data was gathered on may 4th 2020.
updated information will be available in
the description below
as of writing this script there have
been a total of more than 3.6 million
reported cases of coronavirus
it's worth noting that these are the
official reported cases the actual
number is likely much higher
of those infected over 250 000 have died
and just shy of 1.2 million have
recovered
one month ago on april 4th the world had
reported just over 1.2 million cases
that means the global number of cases
has tripled in a single month
as of may 4th the united states has the
most cases of coronavirus with 1.2
million confirmed
followed by spain with 248 000 cases
then italy with 212
000 and the uk with 192 000. according
to the new york times the u.s government
projects daily coronavirus deaths in the
country will nearly double by june 1st
you can follow various live trackers
online two of which are linked in the
description below
looking at these numbers it's clear that
we're still very much in the middle of
this pandemic
especially if cases in the u.s grow as
projected and we're unable to contain
the spread
but how does this compare to past
pandemics we'll start with the obvious
historical comparison
the 1918 spanish flu outbreak named not
for its place of origin
but for the fact that spain allowed free
reporting on the disease which led to
the association
in 1918 the world was embroiled in one
of the greatest conflicts in human
history
which would later become known as world
war one the global mass mobilization of
troops and overcrowding and military
camps contributed greatly to the spread
of a particularly deadly strain of
influenza
throughout march of that year outbreaks
of flu-like symptoms were reported in
the u.s
it started to get noticed when over 100
soldiers at a military camp in kansas
contracted the illness
within a week that number had quintupled
the first public health report came
on april 5th 1918. the report stated
that there had been 18 severe cases and
three deaths in haskell kansas
in the following weeks infected soldiers
shipped off to france to fight in the
war
unfortunately for the u.s the disease
had already found a foothold in the
country
and thanks to a recent piece of
legislation called the sedition act
which criminalized the publishing of any
information that might hinder the war
effort the people of the united states
had little idea of what was headed their
way
newspapers shot down the advice of the
country's medical experts downplayed the
danger and the number of cases exploded
in philadelphia alone 14 500 people were
killed by the spanish flu
necessitating mass graves over the
course of the next year
the spanish flu pandemic infected over a
third of the world's population and
killed over 50 million people
675 000 in the us alone the world had
experienced three waves of outbreak
a mild one in early 1918 then a mutated
far deadlier one in the fall that could
kill a perfectly healthy 20 year old in
under 24 hours
then finally one last wave in the spring
of 1919 that fell somewhere between the
two
worse than the first wave but not nearly
as severe as the second
we hear a lot in the news today about
social distancing and flattening the
curve which means keeping the number of
new cases below the capacity of the
healthcare system
while the people of the early 1900s may
not have used the same terminology
they did employ many of the same
measures we're taking today many cities
recommended wearing masks
they closed schools and prohibited large
public gatherings of course there
were some cities that chose not to take
these measures and suffered greater
outbreaks than those that did
but overall the 1918 social distancing
plan worked
at least at first as the number of new
cases began to decline
these preventative measures were lifted
to help ease the strain on the
struggling economy
unfortunately the disease was still very
much a threat and the newly relaxed
restrictions caused that third wave you
see in the chart
the spanish flu really represents the
perfect storm for a pandemic
global war and mass exposure to infected
people a lack of understanding of
viruses which wouldn't actually be
discovered for a few more years
and a suppression of the reality of the
danger all of these factors combined
with the fact that the spanish flu was
incredibly deadly
worked together to create the worst
pandemic the modern world had seen
a lot has changed since 1918. we have a
much greater understanding of viruses
and how they work
our medical treatments are more advanced
and in theory it's easier to get more
accurate and timely information during a
crisis
if that's the case we should expect more
recent pandemics to have been less
severe
let's take a look at the remaining few
that occurred between 1918 and today
in more recent decades we've seen the
asian flu in 1957 to 58
the hong kong flew from 68 to 70 sars
from 2002 to 2003
swine flu from 09 to 2010 ebola from
2014 to 2016
and now kovid 19 beginning in late 2019.
as you can see
coronavirus is already much deadlier
than most of the recent pandemics the
notable exceptions are the asian flu and
hong kong flu
the two oldest on the list part of the
reason for this is each diseases are
zero or how infectious they are kovid 19
has an r0 of 2.5
meaning each infected person will likely
infect two and a half other people in
the area
by comparison some diseases such as
measles have an r0 of 16
but this infectiousness rating isn't the
only factor
after all sars had a rating of 3.5 and
the death toll only reached 770 people
why has coronavirus spread so much more
rapidly part of the reason is the long
incubation period of covid19
on average infected people don't start
to show symptoms for two weeks
and some never show any symptoms at all
despite being contagious the entire time
sars had an incubation period of just
seven days so it became apparent you
were sick much more quickly and you
could take steps to prevent infecting
other people
these are the main factors contributing
to the unchecked spread of coronavirus
despite sars having a mortality rate of
almost 10 compared to covet 19's
tentative three and a half to five
percent
covid19 has killed far more people
simply because it spreads long before
people realize they're infected
ebola is a similar story it had a
mortality rate of upwards of 50 percent
but infected people looked very sick and
disease transmission required direct
contact with infected bodily fluids
that doesn't seem to be the case with
coronavirus one thing that all of these
outbreaks have in common is their
duration
they all lasted at least one year with
sars swine flu and ebola all lasting
closer to two years or longer
interestingly the spanish flu asian flu
and hong kong flu
all consisted of multiple waves of
infection with the second deadlier than
the first
whereas the more recent outbreaks have
mostly consisted of a single drawn out
period
of infection based on what we've seen
from kovid 19 so far
it looks like we're probably on track
for a one year ordeal we've seen that
when cities relax their social
distancing guidelines
cases in that area spike again with the
u.s weighing whether to open back up
with the disease still very present
we'll likely see another major wave in
the fall some experts suggest it might
last even longer
up to two years or more depending on how
effective containment measures are
but a single one to two year pandemic is
only one of the potential scenarios
another possibility is the coronavirus
going from pandemic to endemic that is
becoming a seasonal illness that we have
to deal with forever
humans already have three endemic
seasonal strains of influenza
and there are other diseases like
tuberculosis that have also become
endemic
there's really no way to say for certain
whether covid19 will go the way of sars
and ebola
or become an unwelcome addition to our
annual illness list
if it does become endemic we'll
hopefully be able to rely on an
effective vaccine to keep ourselves safe
which most experts think will be
available within a year or so
so while we're all going a little stir
crazy do your best to stay safe and not
interact with other people unnecessarily
we still have a ways to go before we're
done with coronavirus
if you'd like to learn more about the
coronavirus and the confusion and chaos
surrounding its spread and origin i
highly recommend you watch the
coronavirus epidemic on curiosity stream
it's a fascinating look at how the world
responds to a rapidly spreading virus
and the measures we can take to stem the
tide of infection
if you watch my videos you'll know i'm a
big fan of curiosity stream it's an
online streaming service with thousands
of non-fiction titles from some of the
best filmmakers in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
the coronavirus epidemic and they've got
a bunch of material on technology and
outer space which are some of my
favorites
their giant catalog includes content on
science nature astronomy technology and
lifestyle among others
unlimited access starts at just 299 a
month and has a special offer just for
you guys
you can get a free trial by following
the link below curiosity stream is
available on just about every platform
you can imagine
so wherever you are you'll always have
access to great interesting content
as an added bonus your curiosity stream
subscription now comes with a free
nebula subscription
nebula is a new streaming platform built
by and for creators like wendover
productions real engineering kurtz
kazakh and of course
second thought and many others it's a
place for us to try new things and make
original content that just wouldn't be
possible on youtube
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you visit
curiositystream.com
second thought if you enjoyed this
episode consider dropping a like
if not a thumbs down while you're here
check out some of my other work
i have videos on all sorts of topics and
i bet you'll find something you'll enjoy
remember to subscribe if you'd like to
see more episodes like this one and
click the bell to be notified each time
i upload a new video
thanks for watching and i'll see you in
the next one